good pitching matchup today jesus
lizardo who will turn
23 tomorrow we'll go for these he's
three and two in a 4-1-2 era
he likes to work fast and anderson
drilled that one to right field and
it's going to fall in front of marcanna
for a lead off hit for the white sox
so two on two out here's the delivery
now to mccann swung out of miss
on a fastball up and away mccann strikes
out the white sox leaf runners at first
and third they fail to score with the
a's coming up in the bottom half
and right-hander lucas giolito who's
really tough
to go for the white sox he's four and
three and a 3.48
and the author of a no-hitter earlier
3-1 simeon
drives one to center luis robert on a
well-hit ball but luis robert about four
steps in
made the play so these go down one two
three and after one
he is in the white sox no score and luis
robert had a tough time down the stretch
he assists turns ready and deals and
it's swung on and missed
good pitch off-speed fish that was down
and chased by louise robert for the
first down that'll bring up the angle
adam engel starting in right field today
will get the at-bat o2
to left and well hit at the wall
it is gone adam angle
starts the scoring off for the white sox
with a home run to left
and it's one nothing white sox here in
the second inning here's the fish now to
garcia swung onto this down garcia
goes so four strikeouts for lizardo back
on the bound with
the top of the order coming up adam
engel the difference in this game
anderson
on the ground and right on through tim
anderson's two for two
19 homers 60 rbis this year for brayu
abreu drives that one toward left center
field on its way and it is gone
by plenty the mvp candidate jose abreu
second home run for the white sox and
they take a three-nothing lead
and sure enough absolutely crushed out
of
oakland's coliseum to left-center field
and the game starts opening up
as the white sox picking on another
left-handed pitcher early in this game
six up and six down for the white sox
ace two on one there's a high fly ball
to deep left field backing up on that
one larry garcia he'll make the catch
right near the warning track
on the ground to short anderson
two down o2 against that high fastball
to right field
engels got it lined up and lucas giolito
is rolling along he is retired all nine
hitters he and the white sox lead three
nothing
chicago white sox the seventh seed in
the american league playoff bracket on
the road for all of these wild card
series games
angle hit another ball hard and that one
is off the wall
grossman's gonna play the carrum angle
with that speed easily into second
with a one-out double well we sort of
figured it was a real short leash for
lizardo now after those home runs and
he's out of the game another 002
that's right there for strike three
called good fast fall off the knees it
freezes garcia he's going to look
that'll bring up robbie grossman and now
the 2-2 pitch swing and a miss strike
three
second strikeout for lucas giolito and
two away here in the fourth inning
so here's giolito working out to simeon
he hits one in the air
and another one two three inning for
lucas gilito he's faced the minimum
through four
the a's are still looking for their
first base runner of the game
olson strikes out swinging so there's a
swing and miss against the high fastball
staring in he's got the o2 sign and the
pitch
is a smack into center field coming on
is louise robert a sit slot he makes the
catch around waist high
and he was able to make the play getting
down to both knees
and lamb skies that one of the air to
center field
luis robert drifting back track and at
the wall we'll pull that one in
and yet another one two three inning for
lucas giolito and the white sox
we've played five white sox three a's
nothing how many base runners has he
allowed
that would be none in his first playoff
start
now the 2-2 pitch and that is strike
three call
four strikeouts now for lucas giolito
and the first 16 in a row set down by
lucas one ball two strike pitch
and pinder swings and misses for strike
three back-to-back strikeouts here in
the sixth five in the game for lucas
giolito
and the o2 to murphy swing and a miss
strike three inning over
one two three for the sixth consecutive
time
go the oakland a's the first 18 in a row
set down in order here by lucas giolito
after six
lucas giolito has been perfect through
six innings
not one base runner for the a's as the
top of the order comes up for the third
time through
turns with the 2-2 swung on grounded up
the middle there's the basic
first one for the athletics no surprise
la stella
threw the middle of the diamond with no
shift and the a's do get their first
base runner it's a lead off single
three and two grossman having a good
battle here he strikes out swinging 94
right on the outside
seven strikeouts for giolito 3-2 pitch
swing and a miss strike three two away
here in the seventh inning eight
strikeouts now for giolito
three nothing white sox seventh inning
fastball right down the middle popped up
remember there's all this foul territory
at the coliseum enough room
for mankato to come over and make the
catch and olson is gone
no runs one hit one man left after seven
soria out of the a's bullpen veteran
right-hander for
the top of the eighth granddaughter
drives one to deep right field
that's the third white sox home run of
the game
and it's four nothing as yasmani
grandahl
here in the eighth inning after going
over three with a couple of strikeouts
delivers on a high change up here he is
starting the eighth so
we get more than a bonus in a four run
game with the lead
lead off walk that ball is drilled into
right field that's going to be a base
hit one hop to engel
canna is going to turn and go to third
first and third
nobody out the a's offense coming to
life and with that 100 pitches into his
playoff debut oh he gets to keep the
ball
building their best chance loriano on
the ground is short anderson
charged it got the out at second that's
the only out they'll get
canna comes in to score so the a's are
on the board
so now the a's are down to their final
out 2-2
olson strikes out swinging and colemay
gets the save the white sox with a
very impressive overall performance
riding
the pitching of lucas giolito the power
of their sluggers